好 今天手上有半導體股票的朋友
一定挺開心的
可是心裡面也會有點毛毛的
如果又還來不及
在這段時間上車的
凱哥也要來分享
事實上有些股票
就算今天大漲還是相對便宜
我發現中總在你前面
都會先幫你塞一個梗
等你來接
對啊 好像不跳進去不行
好 我們先來看
任勳哥說明年的晶片要翻倍了
當然 營收都要成長70%了
所以大大應該要來台灣
來等一下幫我們聊這個
投信也在轉了
從金融股開始轉到
像CPU或是半導體股了
是 我們現在解一下
中董長的這個MHCI
你要知道
MHCI基本上
正面對決
它要考量到流通性的問題
對 不是市值到就可以了
它考量流通性問題
所以剛剛那三檔
我個人覺得
可能短線
最會長的可能是雍智
你看
但是會讓MHCI的
可能是盟利
對 我剛剛講
因為要考量到流通性的問題
因為他剛剛點名之後
我就特別看了一下用字
今天外資大敲用字
所以感覺不太單純
而且他最近的買超大戶
今天又大買
所以我說他可能是
會長得比較兇的
但是會納入MACI的
可能會是盟利
2464的盟利
所以我等於是替中華膽
選了一檔股票
是盟利
他上禮拜也選這檔
我投了盟利
是
你們兩個不要在那邊
零零相通了好嗎
這樣我們看我們自己的
接下來就是
黃仁勳講說
2027年的晶片效果要增加一倍
所以它讓大家吃一顆定心碗
因為之前大家擔心說
AI可能要開始什麼 踩煞車了
但是告訴你說什麼
它從要從476一直跳到1080
未來6G要大幅的成長
而且這裡面其實看到一個很重要的關鍵
就是細光子
因為細光子其實未來怎麼樣
未來才會到位 2028年
所以你現在在講什麼
AI會造成人類的滅絕什麼
其實看科幻片比較快一點
現實是沒有那麼快
所以這樣講之後今天怎麼樣
今天整個大盤就
整個AI
暴動
這不是被動 是暴動
而且今天以這個台積電的子弟兵
創意 率先 創新高
而且最近頭新一直在買
所以他今天是
應該講今天是重中之重
沒有什麼問題
第二是聯電
聯電是今天漲的比台電還要多
而且這一波 投信也大買
結果我們看到產物設備的裡面
材料的中砂也亮燈
然後散熱的高麗跟雙紅也紛紛亮燈
那這個部分可能大家比較關心台達
不過台達還在緩步的
在慢慢的墊底的這個部分
所以我們等一下再來看
好 那我們來看
我們之前有講過雙紅
我說投信還沒領情
外資已經開始買了
後來投信就開始回來買
領情了
開始回來買
股價也怎樣也就拉上去了
這是週型態
週型態是已經過了前面的高點的位置
而且它距離前高一步之遙
所以它今天有點稍微
尾盤有點稍微被壓一下
但是我覺得看起來還會繼續往上走
那你看到買賣超的部分是
17000多張對3900多張
所以看起來還是一個買方的趨勢
沒有什麼改變
但是它在漲的時候
他就會把齊鴻
建設這個族群通通都帶上來
因為他們算是一整個族群的股票
他不會是單一檔
中砂比較尷尬
因為他是金貝
金貝公店裡面除了他以外
還有另外一種就是8028
森陽辦也有這一塊
可是森陽辦比較多是再生金元所以他就會受到再生金元這塊的市場的影響所以他相對來講可能就沒有表現那麼漂亮你看這是中砂的部分基本上投心也是大買
投心也是大買
而且你看這是周的型態
周的大量高就在這裡
之前拉回來整理完之後
就噴出去了
而且今天是報大量
符合總統講的
這個大量要小心一點
今天反而是要比較小心
對 因為報大量
其實投心沒有買那麼多
我投心沒有買
而且我外資今天是稍微減碼的方向
所以創高後反而我們要注意一下
對 所以不見得是創高就一定要去追
我們來看一下最近投信在幹嘛
投信最近因為要升息
所以他們相對於比較保守
他們就買超比較多的金融股
可是我們從他們在買超的部分
我們看到有一些AI的電子股
例如說像聯電 例如說像什麼
廣達 強茂 南亞
這是相對來講他們在大盤
在落色的情況之下
還是比較積極在佈局的
這個AI電子股
在上柜的部分
你可以看到
他們就沒有什麼金融股可以買了
就買比較多的什麼
的電子股
這裡面有一些是
買上去的
有一些是壓下來的
是
例如說
齊邦是買上去的
是
我記得富橋應該也是買了
幾個禮拜了
基本上還停在這個地方
對
那像這個光潔是被動元件
心犬是封測
對
那其實這邊還是有一些是
比較偏保守的
對
例如說像
星象這些
就比較偏殖利率
這邊還有聯亞
聯亞
所以我們可以看到這個族群裡面
其實有一個很隱藏的題材
就是CPU
CPU就是像聯亞 奇邦
其實這些都綁著CPU在繞
其實星權也是
因為它也是比較偏
CPU的測試的部分
所以其實如果你說
在這個CPU測試有兩家
就是奇邦加星權
所以告訴你
其實CPU還是目前的重重之重
重重之重
好 接下來看的是
最近投信一直在买的聯電
大復活了
對啊 我之前不是在笑嗎
我說什麼 投信拼命的賣
對不對
可是他現在卻慢慢往上
我說外資怎麼樣 一直狂買
對 外資是狂買
那是在講說台積電產能溢出來的部分
因為在成熟製程的部分
台電不積極 他是把它溢出來了
那台電的產能
成熟製程就交給世界先進
那還有一部分就到聯電來
那聯電今天會漲
還有跟一個有關係
就是他也要跨入CPU
是 他也要跨入CPU
所以最近這個投信就猛買
但是其實如果你看
買賣券商其實感覺不太出來
對耶 打平而已
但是因為我們的投信怎樣
就是猛買
所以它是從原本的負轉正
投信買兩萬八
一萬一這樣買
而且看起來它就快要逼近前高了
對啊
逼近前高在這裡
但是它高點有大量
所以要努力一下
所以接下來它可能就要進入震盪的位置
震盪的位置
所以不見得說
我們今天在講你就立刻
下禮拜就第一個時間要買
其實稍微看一下型態
結果我們在講說有切入CPO的
測試的部分的奇邦
他也是之前有殺過來
這個股災好慘好慘
往上走
那也現在算中未節
那你看他的大量基本上在這裡
對
大量快要碰到了
所以他下禮拜就要表態了
好
下禮拜就要表態
但是看起來會不會成功
會喔
投信超通常
因為投信跟外資都是站在買方
對
投信在外賣買方
而且你看這個買賣超大部分
5萬多對4萬5千多
看起來是一副會上去的樣子
因為你看這兩個都是外資
都是外資
所以你其實說是投信在買
倒不如說其實外資是在裡面作證
是 對
等於是外資在裡面互生
也等於前一陣子的風波應該已經沒事了好我們剛才我們再更早之前有講到其實這兩家都是屬於聯電集團所以慢慢再往前走基本上子弟平均會跟著我往上走
接下來我們來看到CPU的主要的股票
就是聯亞 有回檔了
對 聯亞你看這是州的型態
州的大量高在這裡
州的大量低在這裡
所以等於是回撤州大量低
那日就不用講了
日目前就是卡在這裡
卡在這裡沒有站上
但是因為我們剛剛講
你州的角度來看
角度來看它大量地已經站上了
所以看起來就會慢慢怎麼樣
慢慢墊高往上走
所以它
因為它是CPU的主要股票
所以這個族群要往上推
它一定要往上走
否則這個股票就會上不去
這個族群會下來
那買賣超是比較平均的
買賣超比較平均的
但是投信還在加碼
好 開始就加碼起來了
所以我覺得因為我們剛剛講了
因為這個行情
開始從保守轉區基金
尤其我們剛剛專案講說
中秋之後要大買特買
所以看起來
中休前一天
就要再大買特馬
就要買科技股
所以看起來他們就後世看好
那你看
Mavio其實在出手搶產人
因為他在搶這個
矽光子的這個
上游的連化音的晶片
他是從可插拔的地方
間接的跳進NPO的部分
所以這也會導致
我們最近在講
就昨天在講的鬼故事
就是說因為CPU上來了
整個這個CCL會被壓抑
因為相對來講這個路徑是不一樣的
但是這個不是現在
這是2028年
不是現在
所以你現在會不會講的太早了
那你不可能說
為了2028年這些高階的財品都不做
都不見步了 不可能
對 沒有辦法
所以它基本上還是
我個人還是覺得還是鬼故事的
這個方向比較多
那接著是
我們來看今天整個
細光子其實都是漲的
從連電一直到我們剛剛的齊邦
跟星全
其實這一段其實都是漲的
那這裡面今天比較特殊的就是
先前有休息的華星光
還有像環雨KY
今天就大漲
那最近其實你可以看到
玉金光一先大漲了
今天換大力光開始大漲
因為它又列地了
超猛的
所以其實大家開始對它又有點期待
對啊
因為它最近被外資降頻之後
股價也稍微下來
好 那我們來看全新
我已經講過了
再回大蛋糕的時候
就是可以參與的機會
對 所以你看它已經
這個大蛋糕離得好遠
好遠喔
是啊 好強喔
接著已經馬上要創這個大量高了
對
那這是日線的角度
那還能追他嗎
外資投信還在追啊
投信這兩天竟然還在追
投信還在追啊
雖然外資有點賣
可是還不太理他
為什麼
因為外資本來就買很多了
買了8000多張
所以投信就有一點點慢了呢
算是
因為你看這邊
買賣超的變化
其實是將近兩倍量
將近兩倍量
所以看起來是還會往上走
而且它這個部分
感覺有一點原本的主力賣飛了
主力賣飛了
因為過去的全新有一個Local的主力
就是華南永昌桃園
可是它已經被洗掉了
所以接下來就是法能控盤
不是主力控盤
所以看起來它會繼續往上走
我記得小哥有講過
桃園的地緣分點在買全新
這不是我講的 是小哥已經先講了
因為我們現在要一棒船一棒
大家都要先把坑挖起來
他等一下說這個凱根講過
我就不太多講
這是大家比較少注意到的光環
但是感覺也有一點點的什麼
味道出來了
其實光環很強耶這一波
它也有點味道出來了
你看大量在這裡
我們這是從周的大量來看
周大量高是站上的
那距離周的大量高
這邊還有一個大量高量稍微小一點的目前就在這個中間的地方整理那日的大量呢基本上它就卡在這裡了好 為什麼特別講它因為它也是進入CPO的階段
而且其實國內的公司
都是一環接一環
就是像波羅威幫誰代工
誰又幫誰代工
所以我只要講嘛
我說華星光那時候不太好
因為它把聯亞的東西做壞掉了
對 可是因為市場就是很缺嘛
所以你把東西做壞掉
不代表別人不會給你訂單
所以他就接馬費額訂單
所以他的獲利也跟著上來
為什麼最近投信比較敢積極買華興光
就是實質的數字有出來
他不太是夢的感覺
也比較有數字
你看光環的部分也是一樣
一萬兩千多張
對八千多張
也明顯是買大於賣
買大於賣
所以我覺得他也可以稍微看一下
可以看一下
接著我們看的是龍頭的大力光
是 買地像買菜
對 他最近很積極的在擴廠
很積極的在擴廠
可是大家對它的感覺就是
P已經拉很高了
因為其實你獲利也沒有跳很多出來
它沒有
對 最近出iPhone
其實感覺對它沒有什麼影響
雖然這iPhone 18最近在熱賣當中
可是我們來看
基本上它也是有特定人在買
8000多張對5700多張
所以表示有人覺得說
它本來的數字就很好了
那你現在因為有細光值
就可以把本益比什麼推高
我們來看它的型態
這是它的大量在這裡
是
然後這邊有一個大量
所以它等於是回撤了這裡
它沒有碰到喔
你仔細看一下喔
它的周大量高在這裡
我來畫一下
畫不太出來
有一點點
大概在這個地方
對
有點接近沒有碰到
但是很妙的是
最近有好多檔的ETF
都要把大力光剔除
為什麼
就是可能覺得它的數字
可能沒有跟上
而且本益比它很高
所以會有點壓力囉
很難講 為什麼
因為我剛剛講吧
8000多張對5000多張
對 所以你說投信要賣
而且投信還在買
就是有主
被動的ETF要把它提出來
是 主動式的
對 有被動式的ETF要提出來
可是主動式的在買
所以這個很尷尬
然後再來就是
你看這個日的大量
日的大量因為它之前有被降頻
所以它離日的大量有一個距離
所以我覺得到這邊可能會稍微整理一下
也不會立刻噴上去
但是因為最近我觀察到
像玉金光就有特定的阻力在收
所以它就會把整個族群帶上來
而且現在CPU又很夯
所以很難講說
它這邊洗完之後
會不會就直接再往上走
很難講
所以我覺得還是可以再觀察一下
在這一塊的部分
那你說其實整個族群上面來看
基本上其實大力光跟剛剛的族群
其實它比較沒有這麼的直接
因為它比較算是後面的
因為你看他還在買地
所以你說他現在大產出
因為他的重點是CPU
他還在買地
你跟像華星光這種
實際上馬上速度就開出來的
是不太一樣的
所以你看投信買的狀況也不太一樣
投信買華星光就是閉著眼睛
幾千幾千在他買
可是大信光就是
你看買一買有點縮手
然後又買一買有點縮手
所以我覺得他們相對的走勢
應該比較慢
這波會上來
我覺得都是少年股神做出來的
了解
就是因為是高價股
比較沒有散戶
所以少年股神就很敢在這上面
大張旗鼓
是
好 還有高雄的三多哥
再幫小哥挖個坑
這個是小哥
好 所以剛剛講到的
投信其實前一陣子真的相對保守
有可能會在第四季趕快回來買
那看來對CPU來說
他們的興趣是高的
是
數字如果已經開始開出來的
更有興趣了
沒錯
好 這邊非常謝謝凱哥
謝謝昭華